[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش الملف الثاني
في ظل حكمه طالبان التعليم الفتيات
الافغانيات بين المعاناه والواقع المرير
حق مسلوب وطريق صعب للوصول اليها فبعد ان
اغلق باب التعليم في وجوههن وحرمنا منه
لمن هن بعد الصف السادس عراقيل اخرى بدات
تظهر للفتيات الافغانيات قد تدفع الاهالي
الى الخوف والتوقف عن ارسال الفتيات الى
المدارس وفي الجديد هذه المره مشاهدينا
موجه تسمم وصلت الى ابواب المدارس
الابتدائيه في حادثه هي الاولى في عهد
النظام طالبان الحالي اعادت ذكرى مشابهه
شهدتها مدارس الفتيات في ايران سابقا
اداره التعليم في حكومه طالبان اكد التعرض
العشرات من الطالبات للتسمم في منطقه
شمال افغانستان حيث اصيبت 60 طالبه من
مدرسه النسوان كبوت اب و17 طالبه اخرى في
مدرسه نسوان فايز اباد واشارت التعليم الى
ان العمليه خطط لها اشخاص مجهول الهويه
حيث تم استهدافه المدرستين واحده تبع
الاخرى لكن المعلومات الاوليه اظهرت ان
شخصا لديه طاقين دفع لطرف ثالث لتنفيذ هذه
الهجمات تجدر الاشاره الى انه هو في عهد
الحكومه الافغانيه السابقه وقعت عده هجمات
تصميم بما في ذلك هجمات يشتبه في انها
بالغاز على مدارس للفتيات
في افغانستان الخوف من المستقبل المجهول
متوسط في اوساط النساء قوانين كثيره
اصدرتها طالبان ضد المراه الافغانيه بعضها
استبعدها من الوظائف العامه والاخر اغلق
باب التعليم في وجهها
تاخر دخول الفتيات الافغانيات فوق 12 عاما
الى المدرسه
ادى الى حرماني مليون ومئه الف طالبه من
الانتفاع بالتعليم النظامي
اليونسكو 80% من الفتيات والشابات
الافغانيات ممن هن في عمر الدراسه خارج
المدرسه
30% من الفتيات الافغانيات لم تطا اقدامهن
المدرسه الابتدائيه على الاطلاق
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من كابول عائشه
قانتل استاذه الجامعيه اهلا بك ومن كابول
عبد الجبار بهير رئيس المركز الافغاني
للدراسات والاعلام اهلا بكم ضيوفي اسمحوا
لي ان ابدا مع الاستاذه عائشه استاذه
عائشه مبدئيا لماذا نحمل حكومه طالبان ما
حدث من تسمم في مدرسين لماذا انتم تحملون
حكومه طالبان وتعتبرون بانها هي المسؤوله
عن حوادث التسمم هذه
نعم الحكومات الطالبان مسؤوله عن
هذه الحوادث لانهم مسؤولون عن
تامين المدارس والتامين تعليم البنات لان
البنات يحرمنا من التعليم الثانوي
هذه الحوادث وشبه هذه الحوادث يمكن ان
يحرمنا البنات من التعليم الابتدائي ايضا
فيعني الطالبين عايشه حضرتك حضرتك تقولي
حضرتك تقولي فقط بانه طالبان تتعمد مثل
هكذا حوادث حتى تمنع الفتيات من الدراسه
لا ليس طالبا تتعمد بل جهات اخرى يريدون
ان
يمارسون مثل هذه الحوادث لان يمنعنا
البنات من التعليم الابتدائي ايضا كما
حرمنا من التعليم الثانوي
التعليم الجامعيه نعم والان هناك حديث حتى
عن تعليم الابتدائي هناك مخاوف من
العائلات سيد عبد الجبار ضيفتي تقول بانه
حتى ان كانت هناك اطراف ثالثه تود منع
البنات الفتيات الصغار من الدراسه في
افغانستان ولكن حركه طالبان كما
اشارت تتحمل مسؤوليتها لانها لم تحميهم من
هذه الحوادث المتكرره ما رايك
طبعا ليس حمايه فقط النساء والفتيات بل
حمايه جميع المواطنين ولكننا نحن الان
نتحدث ولكن اسمحلي اسمح لي سيد عبد الجبار
لما لما تحدث عمليه تسمم في مدارس اخرى
سنتحدث عنها ولكن نحن الان نتحدث عن مدارس
فتيات يوم السبت ويوم الاحد طالتها مواد
تسميم الاخطر من ذلك بانه هناك من صور من
دخل
وحاول تصميم الصفوف والحكومه لم تلقي
القبض عليه حتى الان ما التفسير
يعني طبعا الحكومه اعلنت الحكومه المحليه
في ولايه ساري بول الشماليه اعلنت انهم
يريدون او انهم وراء تواجد من هو المتورط
في هذه القضيه هناك الاف المدارس ليس فقط
هذه مدرستين هاتين في ولايه هناك الاف
المدارس تم تامينها يعني انا فقط اريد ان
اوضح ان ان طالبان او حكومه افغانستان
الاماره الاسلاميه ليست وراء منع الفتيات
من النساء او العمل لكن لا طبعا القراءه
المتشدده لحركه طالبان القديمه كانت من
اهم الماخذ على هذه الحركه وعلى هذه يعني
الفئه السياسيه في افغانستان
الطالبات الان او الفتيات الان يمارسن
عملهن في تعليم الثانوي
والاعداد في الجانب الديني وكذلك يعني فوق
الثاني في القطاع الصحي ليس يعني ان
المراه تماما هي ممنوعه هي تعمل في جميع
القطاعات القطاع الخاص
في داخل الافغاني يقال في داخل الافغاني
بانه صحيح بان تصريحات الافغانيه تصريحات
حركه طالبان تدعم دراسه الفتيات دون سن
12 سنه اعتقد يعني السادسه ابتدائي ولكن
لانها محرجه من ان تضغط عليهن بمنعهن من
الدراسه كما ضغطت على الجامعيات فهي تحاول
ايجاد طرق اخرى باخافه العائلات يعني
اليوم الاب مثلا لن يرسل ابنه الى المدرسه
خوفا من حوادث تسمم
يعني نحن في الواقع الافغاني نرى ان
المراه بكل حريتها في افغانستان تتجول في
اطار المحدد التي حددتها الحكومه
الافغانيه ليس كما كانت هي يعني حره
وتتصرف كما تشاء في الحكومه السابقه انا
لا ادافع عن موقف الحكومي لكن كواقع
افغاني هناك المراه تتجول يعني
لا احد يستطيع ان يلمس المراه بسوء في
افغانستان هناك قرارات صارمه قاطعه صدرت
من الحكومه الافغانيه ان حقوق المراه لابد
ان تتوفر لها يعني الحكم الافغانيه لكن
التعليم لا زالت لا زالت
صحيح حتى صلب حركه طالبه نفسها ولكن
استاذه عائشه ما رايك في كلام ضيفي هو
يقول بانه المراه في افغانستان حره تعمل
تدرس تتعلم تتجول دون ان يطالها اي خطر او
اي مشكله
نعم المراه في افغانستان حره لكن وضع هناك
طالبان على المراه في حكومتهم
القوانين
لمنع تعليمهم تعليمهن وايضا لمنعهن من
العمل في ميادين مختلفه
وبالاخص منعهن من التعليم الثانوي لتعليم
الجامعيه
راينا الحريه ما هذا الحريه لان الطالبان
يمنعهن من حقوقهم
اولى حقوق الذي هو الاولويه حياتهم
التعليم فانهن يمنعنا منهن حرمنا من
التعليم حرمنا من من من العمل
لافهم قراءه حضرتك ما العلاقه بين الحرمان
من التعليم الذي تفضلت بالاشاره له وبين
حالات التسمم
المتكرره وهي قادره ان تكون اعمال شخصيه
او فرديه
ممكن ممكن هذا هذه الحوادث مع القصد من من
الاجانب من من طرف
مع القصد ومع تدبير لان لان ان وضعنا
المواد المسمم في ماء الشرب للطالبات
وهذا ممكن ممكن فرديين وهذا ممكن من جانب
من طرف يريدون ان يمنعنا البنات من هذا
التعليم الثانوي من هذا التعليم الابتدائي
التعليم الابتدائي الذي هو المجال الوحيد
لتعليم للبنات في الافغانستان حاليا وضحت
فكره حضرتك على كل البعض يقول علها تكون
حوادث
استثنائيه ومتفارقه ولا تعمم ولا تتكرر
نحن سنبقى في متابعه هذا الموضوع شكرا
جزيلا لكم من كابول عائشه قانت الاستاذه
الجامعيه ومن كابول كذلك عبد الجبار بهير
رئيس المركز الافغاني للاعلام والدراسات
شكرا لكمما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات